[موسيقى]
ابريل ومايو ويونيو ثلاثه اشهر ارتبطت
بارتفاع درجه الحراره في جنوب اسيا
وتحديدا في المنطقه الممتده بين الهند
وباكستان ولان البلاد اعتدى ذلك قبيله
موسم الامطار فلا شيء يدعو للقلق لكن ما
حدث في صيف 2015 كان اكثر من مقلق بل ربما
هو اسوا الكوارث التي عرفتها المنطقه خلال
العقد الماضي فما القصه
فيما يعا عام 2015
تعرضت اجزاء من الهند لموجه حراريه شديده
شهد ارتفاعا كبيرا بلغ ذروته في السابع
والعشرين من مايو حيث تجاوز الدرجه
الحراره 47 درجه مئويه في بعض المناطق ثم
انتقلت الموجه لباكستان لتشمل اجزاء واسعه
من البلدين
لم يكن من السهل البقاء خارج المنزل وحتى
داخله اذا ما اخذنا بعين الاعتبار انقطاع
الكهرباء عن بعض المنازل بسبب اجهاد شبكه
الطاقه الكهربائيه في بعض المناطق فاصبحت
المراوح ومضخات المياه ومكيفات الهواء
عديمه الفائده اما بالنسبه للمدن الساحليه
جعل الهواء الرطب درجات الحراره المرتفعه
اكثر خطوره ومهدده للحياه
الاجهاد الحراري والجفاف وضربه الشمس من
سكان الاكثر ضعفا من كبار السن واولئك
الذين يعملون خارج المنازل كعمال البناء
وسائقي سيارات الاجره ما اثقل كاهل القطاع
الصحي في ما اصيبت غالبيه قطاعات العمل
بالشلال
تسببت الحراره الشديده في مقتل ما لا يقل
عن 2300 شخصا في الهند ووقعت معظم الوفيات
في ولايتي
انجانا بجنوب شرق الهند كما تم الابلاغ عن
العديد من الوفيات في ولايات اوديشا وجرات
والبنغال الغربي
جلب وصول الامطار الموسميه الى الهند
فيما تاخر التاثيرات التبريد لتصل الى
باكستان المجاوره التي بقيت تحت تاثير
ارتفاع درجات الحراره لمعظم شهر يونيو
وبشكل اساسي في مدينه كراتشي الساحليه
فيما كانت البلاد تستقبل طقوس شهر رمضان
مع انتهاء الموجه بباكستان سجلت على الاقل
1300 وفئه قالت الحكومه ان 25% منهم كانوا
من المشردين الذين لا يملكون ماوى حيث تم
تنفيذ عمليات دفن جماعي لنحو 200 جثه لم
يطالب بها احد فيما بقي ما يقرب من اي
مصاب يتلقون العلاج في المستشفيات
وفيما غادر شبح الموت القاره الهنديه صنفت
هذه الموجه الحراريه بانها الخامسه بين
اكثر الموجات فتكا في التاريخ
[موسيقى]